all of microscope is is a really
powerful magnifying glass the great
advantage of the light microscope yet
over the electron microscope is the fact
that you can you can zoom into the cell
you can focus into the cell without
harming it so because of that you could
look at the natural function of the cell
in real time so what was the problem the
problem is if you focus on the light to
a point you will have a diffraction
Bloor the lens diffracts the light and
as a result you can't focus the the beam
to anything smaller than the wavelength
approximate wavelength of the light
itself so that means that if you are
hoping to look at an object that's less
than the wavelength of light you do not
have a resolution that is smaller than
about 200 to 400 nanometers now it turns
out that molecules are about 3
nanometers in size so the problem is if
you want to look at individual molecules
all you will see with diffraction
limited imaging is big blobs of about
200 nanometer blurry spots
of course I knew that it was impossible
to focus the light more sharply than
about half the wavelength of light but
it doesn't mean that it's impossible to
generate say spots of excited molecules
that are much sharper than that and one
way of doing it is to accept that large
area of excitation but then use another
beam of light that switches off the
molecules at the outer part of that area
of excitation and if you do that you end
up with a region that is much smaller
than the initial region and therefore
you have a much smaller spot of
fluorescence and if you have a much more
sportive presence you can use that to
take sharper images you just scan that
spot across the specimen and in the end
you will see more details because the
sharper the spot the more detail to get
the fundamental principles of these two
imaging methods are similar or I would
even say the same because they are both
taking advantage of the fact that the
molecules are switchable you could take
the blurry spot given off by an
individual molecule and if you could
switch off that spot you could then fit
the spot using mathematical equations
such that you could determine the center
of that spot and that center is where
the molecule is
so our microscope uses laser light for
illumination and we actually have
several different colors from violet all
the way to red for illuminating the
sample we have a fast shutter system
that is able to switch the laser light
on and off very quickly in order to
activate and deactivate the switchable
floor for us of course in many
biological samples molecules are so
densely packed so their images overlap
and then you lost the ability to fit
this single molecule in which to find
the center so then we thought hard about
the problem then we came up with this
trick the trick is you switch on these
molecules separately in small groups
where each of the molecules that have
been switched on are far enough apart so
that their spots don't overlap
eventually I get the sufficient number
of molecular positions and then I stack
them together to form an image so this
is the storm image that we generated
from all of our individual localizations
and in this sample you're looking at
microtubules in a cell if you zoom in
really closely you can see that you know
had its most basic level the image is
just made up of a bunch of locations and
then you know when you zoom out on all
these crosses there's millions of
crosses I can compare this image to the
conventional resolution image and you
can see that in the conventional
conventional resolution you can't you
can't make out the individual
microtubules but in the storm image
they're easy to resolve for the first
time you just saw this this absolutely
spectacular
distribution of tens of thousands
molecules inside the mitochondria and
when I saw that I just and I was ready
to sort of fall on the floor
you can see now
details for example structures in the
mitochondria or structure in the nucleus
or say even for example a neuron to see
what it's doing when it's learning I
think there's a whole world down there
to be discovered with this folks visible
light this is exactly why I loved
microscopy because people say that
seeing is believing right I saw it I
said this thing you know it has a future
you
you